Well,
they say that's the secret to being a draw is appeal to women because they're
the ones that decide what to do at night.
Yes.
Yeah.
Right.
Like there's not a whole lot of chicks begging to go to slayer.
And if they are,
take them.
That's it.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
They want to go see someone cute.
I bet there's probably a disproportionate number of chicks going to see aqua
man.
I bet.
If you allow,
yeah.
If you looked at the number of women that want to go see a superhero movie and
uh,
the number of women that want to go see aqua man.
Yeah.
It's off the charts and aqua man's favor.
Someone should do a study.
That's a handsome man.
Well,
he's his name.
Jason Mamoa.
He was Badass.
Game of Thrones.
He's a beast to super nice guy too.
I'm married a guy in a whole foods and nail sweetheart,
sorta telling you.
Oh sweetheart.
He is like,
you're so handsome.
It's confusing.
So call and beautiful women are feelings,
right?
Yeah.
Leave that guy.
My wife said it best.
She said he's everybody's type.
She's like,
you know some girls,
Brad Pitt's there type.
You know some girls it's uh,
you know,
fill in the blank.
Yeah.
Jimmy Fallon.
He's everybody's tight
and he's a giant and he's got awesome tattoos.
A fucking nice guy.
Fucking fuck.
Are those his real tattoos?
I don't believe so.
I think that's just for aqua man.
That's his tattoos for aqua man.
What are his real tattoos?
He's got a gang of real tattoos.
The forearm ones I think is is real tattoos.
Yeah.
Boy,
that takes some time and makeup because if he's doing a role where they don't
want that,
that's a lot of time covering that shit up every day.
I don't think they have to cover up shit with him.
Yeah,
it was just that,
that beautiful face.
Get on screen that all those damp and panties do the talking.
See you again tomorrow,
man.
Whew.
Yeah.
Girls are going to that movie.
It's like a phrase.
It's like a porn theater in Times Square in the 70s for women's probably like
slipping their hands.
Then moisture in the air and yourself off all these little heaters.
Cheaters.
Your feet are stuck on the floor.
You think it's the popcorn butter?
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
Yeah.
Um,
how do we get on subject to him?
Aqua man,
girls,
any Clark.
Oh yeah.
Girls deciding what to go sit right there.
Girls would be,
they'd be like,
yeah,
let's go see aqua man.
He be like,
wait a minute.
Thought you hate superhero movies,
whatever you want to go.
Yeah.
She wants to stare at Jason Mamoa.
Right.
He is pretty beautiful.
We watched him on screen,
dammit.
Yeah.
Shit.
I can't hate her.
He thinks some women watch MMA for that reason.
I think some guys are cute.
Fuck yeah.
Not only cute,
but savages.
Right.
I mean the number of women with a
sketchy childhoods that are attracted to MMA fighters can be off the charts.
Yeah.
I want to say that in a very polite way is polite as I could say.
I think even regular women,
I think like lawyers,
like buttoned down women see a cause.
They're around neutered men all day and you're around a guy like,
you know Luke Rockhold is no,
it might be better.
Look in the J's my Ma and he's a UFC middleweight champion.
Beautiful.
Six foot three,
six foot four,
somewhere in that range.
Planning features looks like a model handsome is,
fuck God.
I want to say give them hell yeah.
Ass Kicker.
That's not the best picture on Bro.
That's kind of gets,
that's after a fight scene before the beast.
But point is uh,
there's Garr on t go that one about what?
The blue shorts on.
What you see is a look at that handsome bastard.
Look at him.
He,
yeah,
he's got a good build.
That's the kind of build my wife likes.
She doesn't like it too big.
She likes it like me and him slow down.
You and him are the same.
The fuck
I short.
Girls are watching that guy though.
Like okay,
here's another one.
George Saint Pierre hundred percent.
Look at that beautiful body.
Oh yeah.
George Saint Pierre.
It's beautiful.
Like George Saint Pierre Literally has to beat women away from it.
From me.
I'm busy.
I am busy.
Go to that picture up there.
We're just throwing a punch.
The one right there.
Look at that.
I mean,
you don't think girls would be begging to have that inside of them.
If I was a woman,
if I was a heterosexual woman and I saw that guy and he was like,
would you like a drink?
I'd be like,
fuck yes,
I'd like a drink.
Yeah.
God Damn you savage.
Let's do this.
Yeah.
I want to drink.
Can we have it after you?
Fuck me.
Yeah.
I don't want to get too drunk.
I want to feel it still.
Woo.
Yeah.